I'm gonna have to miss you all over
again descendants three definitely
proved how much of an awesome actress
you art of Cameron we were stunned by
your amazing acting abilities you are
definitely getting the world's attention
we are all capable of good and bad and
you just hit 30 million followers on
Instagram you are doing really well for
someone so young and you deserve every
bit of the money over but we were
surprised to learn that you weren't the
richest person from The Descendants
franchise the cast of descendants 3 is
living their best life and getting paid
handsomely for it but you'll be
surprised at which star is actually the
richest keep watching to find out dead a
die a good a cur
Jedediah Dekker plays none other than
chad charming but he has a pretty
impressive acting resume he was on a few
episodes of the 100 and has recently
appeared on the Chilean adventures of
Sabrina the doctor he was also in the
Disney movie Tomorrowland and he was one
of the few cast members to appear in all
three descendants movies first off great
new work but when it comes to money
Jedediah is worth the least he comes in
at number 10 with a net worth of about
$200,000 Sara Jeffery next up is the
queen of mean herself Sarah Jeffery
plays Audrey the daughter of Sleeping
Beauty oh she was such a great villain
in descendants 3 playing Audrey really
launched her into success she starred in
a series called shades of blue and now
she is on the reboot of charmed I'm
sorry
I have to go Maggie her official salary
hasn't been disclosed but estimates put
her net worth at around half a million
dollars we're sure that number will just
continue to increase now that she is a
rising star
Thomas Doherty he might play the son of
a pirate but Thomas Doherty has come by
his wealth honestly he sentence to is
Thomas's first a major role but since
then he has appeared in a bunch of
episodes at the lodge epic career times
get jealous now that his time as Harry
Hook is over he has two television shows
in the works look for him in Catherine
the Great and high-fidelity Thomas's net
worth is currently sitting pretty at 1
million dollars he's definitely doing
well Mitchell hope King VIN might be
worth a lot more than his actor Mitchell
Hope Mitchell has a lot and
common with his co-star Thomas Doherty
he'll be starring in descendants was his
first major role and he is also worth 1
million dollars he's estimated to make
between 2000 and $3,500 her Instagram
post Wow
we want to make that much for posting on
social media we are excited to see him
in his upcoming Christmas movie let it
snow
China and McClain we love how China and
McClain portrayed uma in descendants 3
and we are so excited to see more
awesome things from her I bet you lost
some sleep thinking about me on the
loose on China and became famous for
Stine on Disney Channel's ant farm but
she has also been in lots of other
things she was in grown-ups and its
sequel she starred in the Tyler Perry
show House of Pain and recently she has
been in the TV series Black Lightning
China and is one busy girl her net worth
is two million dollars Brenna D'Amico
Jane really grew up throughout the
descendence movies and burnin D'Amico
did a great job playing her sorry
Hawk teen in descendants franchise was
Brenda's very first role but since then
she has appeared in several new things
she starred in a couple of short TV
series for brat productions nothing's
wrong why and she's set to appear in
three upcoming movies including
Adventures of dally and Spanky for his
net worth is estimated at around 2
million dollars dove Cameron you might
be surprised that mal herself is not the
richest of the descendants 3 cast I know
that def Cameron is worth three million
dollars she's best known for descendants
and her time on Disney Channel's Liv and
Maddie she's also a marvel star she
voiced Quinn Stacy and marvel rising
initiation calls fine and dandy in
gwenlyn dia and she also played Ruby on
agents of shield she also starred
opposite Jennifer Aniston in dumpling we
can't wait to see what she does next
booboo Stewart before he played Jay in
descendents booboo Stewart was well
known for another popular movie
franchise he played Seth Clearwater a
young werewolf in the Twilight movies
newest bestest brightest and slowest
booboo has acted in a lot of things
sometimes they are small roles and other
times they are pretty big that's why he
is worth a whopping 4
million dollars that's pretty awesome
for someone so young he turned 25 in
2019 bubu has been really busy he has
one TV show and 11 movies coming out in
the next couple of years
Cheyenne Jackson Cheyenne Jackson stole
our hearts has the coolest villain and
best descendants dad Hades Cheyenne has
been around the acting scene for a while
he is most famous as a Broadway star and
has played lots of famous roles on stage
he also appeared on American Horror
Story for a handful of seasons any last
words
in 2018 he appeared on the TV show
American woman he has also guest-starred
on shows like Glee and 30 rock Cheyenne
is worth five million dollars
Sofia Carson it might surprise you that
Sofia Carson is actually the wealthiest
cast member from descendants three she
could probably buy a starter Castle just
like Evie
before she played the most stylish BK of
course they've only done about a
thousand sketches of her own interest EB
guest-starred on Austin and Ally she
also had several music videos
Sofia is an Instagram influencer she is
also starring as Ava on Pretty Little
Liars
the perfectionist with me and my friends
alone and just like this car she is
currently filming a movie called feel
the beat Sofia's net worth is currently
six million dollars which star did you
think would have the biggest net worth
tell us in the comments thanks for
watching give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things we'll catch you next time
[Music]